I'm pretty bad at quantum mechanics I
talk a lot about physics here on my
channel and I think you guys often
credit me with being more of an expert
than I really am I am doing a PhD in
physics but it's in an area of
biophysics and I learn a lot more now
about the physics of how plants grow
than I do about quantum mechanics and
the physics of how particles behave on a
very small scale but in saying that
quantum mechanics I still find to be an
inherently very interesting field I sort
of think that most people who end up
being interested in physics in some way
come into this interest through either
quantum mechanics and the strangeness
they've heard about at that scale or
through something like astrophysics and
the vastness and the mysteries out there
things like dark matter and dark energy
so I think quantum physics is a topic
that a lot of sort of hobbyist
physicists like to learn people that are
not necessarily trained and physics
often like to read ideas about quantum
physics but one barrier to really
understanding some of quantum physics is
the mathematics behind it and quantum
physics is a math heavy area you simply
can't really understand everything
that's out there and in books online
without being able to understand all the
mathematical underpinnings and frankly
it's pretty complicated so even though
I've passed multiple quantum physics
courses along my physics education like
through my degree I wouldn't call myself
an expert on it and in fact I've
forgotten a lot of the mathematical
underpinnings that go with it and
because pretty much the nature of how I
learned quantum mechanics at you
was studying and cramming for exams and
just trying to get out of assignments
and I sort of spoken before about how I
don't like this approach to learning and
how a lot of what I felt like I learned
during my undec undergrad degree I've
almost forgotten or ayah I never really
learned well because I was just
memorizing a lot of information
memorizing a lot of these mathematical
techniques being able to use them in
needs and so I was pretty good at being
able to like a regurgitate them in that
way but there's still a lot more that I
want to deeply understand about physics
about quantum physics so I thought I'd
take you on a little bit of a journey
with me I'm going to study and revise
some quantum mechanics and specifically
the mathematical underpinnings so I'm
going to basically build up all the math
skills that you need to understand
quantum mechanics and I want to bring
you along with me so this is hopefully
going to be a bit of a series where we
can learn together in a way so whilst I
might have more of a physics and math
starting point I hope that we can sort
of learn together through this it's
going to be a little bit of an
experiment to see what level you guys
enjoy me going at I know some people
that watch my videos have like a degree
or a PhD in physics already some people
just have a mild and just in the subject
so what I'm going to do is work through
some online courses in quantum mechanics
and I'm going to look at the math behind
it so I'm going to move reasonably
slowly and look in this episode at
pretty much linear algebra and how that
applies to quantum mechanics so how you
write out quantum states and how you do
that and in bracket notation this is
really often used in quantum mechanics
but it can be one of the most
off-putting things to see someone who
doesn't understand the notation I think
it comes down to be reasonably simple
any other reason I want to relearn some
of this mathematical notation is because
I know how important it is to
understanding further ideas and I don't
think I understand it as well as I want
to okay so I'm working through a course
called quantum objects on brilliant org
and I'm on their section for
mathematical foundations I'll put a link
down below so that you can find this
course as well and study along with me
if you like what they've spoken about so
far is an experiment in quantum
mechanics called the stern-gerlach
experiment I hope I said that right it's
a pretty important experiment in quantum
mechanics we talked about that
experiment later but first of all we're
going to touch on something that at
first doesn't seem like it's related to
quantum mechanics at all but actually
underpins a lot of the math that's going
on here and it kind of touches on the
essence of something called linear
algebra it's talking about basically
wavelengths of light and how different
wavelengths of light to give you
different colors and so every color of
the rainbow can be described described
pretty simply as a scalar values that's
just meaning that every color on here
corresponds to some wavelength in
nanometers so 600 nanometers yellow so
then were talking about actually the
really famous physicist James Clark
Maxwell who you probably know from
Maxwell's equations and electromagnetism
he was a I guess really influential
scientist and made a lot of
contributions to physics so it's talking
about something that he did where back
when they only had black and white
photography he was trying to get some
color into photographs and sort of
reconstruct some color
so let's see Maxwell captured
black-and-white photos of the same
colorful Scottish tartan using red green
and blue filters that only lit one color
of light through so we had projections
of these red green and blue images and
he combined these projections to try and
recreate the color photo and what did it
look like when he superimposed the
projections well in fact he did produce
an image with all the true colors intact
so we can see he's made the original
like tartan colors
so apparently Maxwell was amazed to see
that any color of the rainbow could be
recreated in this superimposed
projection not just the red green and
blue colors that he had hoped for but
what was amazing is that like yellow
purple are showing up and here even
though no yellow or purple wavelengths
of light were passing through these
filters there's no purple or yellow
wavelengths of light in in these three
images that he was using so yeah here
what it demonstrates is that combining
red and blue light gives you purple
light which appears purple to our eye
exactly the same way that purely purple
light would appear what this is
representing is that a combination of
colors can be represented as a linear
combination so that's what we have
written here it's our first glimpse and
the sort of notation that we're going to
learn it's saying that purple light can
be created from an equal mixture of half
red light and half blue light so that's
what we've got going on here so you can
see that the way they've written purple
white red light and blue light is in
these sort of funny brackets and those
are called kit brackets
here I think you just need to know that
they would present a state so the state
of the light in the first set of
brackets is purple the state of the
light here is red or blue it's just
telling you you know what color the
light is in this description here the
colors red and blue was serving as a
color basis which we combined in linear
combinations to create new colors so
this thing here is the linear
combination of red and blue with equal
parts of each so then it's asking how
many basis wavelengths or colors do we
need that such that we can combine to
produce every color it's saying well if
we just has one color as our basis like
blue then all we could do was create
different shades of blue so if we we are
only using blue light and our linear
combinations we could never create any
other colors we're going to need at
least two colors to create something new
and the answer is that we need three
colors to create a basis to create every
other color of light I think this has to
do was actually like the biology of the
human eye so it's a side effect of how
our eyes perceive light humanised to
take light using three different types
of cell each sensitive to long medium
and short wavelengths which correspond
to red green and blue light so these are
actually the three colors that are gonna
form
our basis in this example so using our
building blocks of red green and blue we
can make any color such as cyan yellow
magenta they're all they're all equal
combinations of the red green and blue
primary building blocks so in this
example there's a half in front of all
the brackets meaning that all these
mixtures are like equal parts of like
these two building blocks but there
would be like a continuous series of
colors that exist where this half could
be any real number so you can sort of
have an infinite combination of the
building blocks to create an infinite
number of new colors there is a question
here is it possible to construct the
color blue through a combination of the
colors red and green bounce here is no
because blue is one of our fundamental
building blocks and we can't use the
other building blocks to make the third
one we sort of need these three building
blocks to start with to make any other
further color this is called the color
space and you can represent it in this
diagram here so the same the three
primary colors are shown as orthogonal
axes since they are mutually exclusive a
purely red source of light has no blue
or green components it is impossible to
represent one primary color as a linear
combination of the others just as it's
impossible to represent a coordinate on
the z axis as a combination of x and y
vectors so here we're starting to move
from a whole color example you're just
like representing it on a grid like
we've got x y and z X's and this whole
thing about orthogonal axes means that
they're at 90 degrees to each other it
just means that the green is one of our
building blocks and it's going in a
different direction to the blue building
block and they're going in a different
direction to the red building what
and you need all three of these to
create a three-dimensional cube
essentially of color when you add two
vectors say the red one and the blue one
and you end up coming out in this
diagonal direction that's where you get
like a pink purple type color so you've
added the red and blue vector and got
something in between
there's then a brief discussion about
normalizing vectors and this means we're
essentially limiting the length of our
victim it's kind of like the intensity
of the light that you want out at the
end you want the intensity to be
constant some values so if you crank up
and down the red blue and green values
you want them to even out such that they
always add to the same intensity
typically for vectors you normalize them
all to be like the unit length or one so
if we want the intensity to be one and
we're adding together two base colors to
get that intensity we'd take a half of
each color and there's a little
discussion here about how you do that
and make sure they do add up to
something consistent and I think that
this example here what the colors really
does give us quite an intuitive idea of
what adding together different states
means in terms of combining to give a
new state okay so let's talk a little
bit more about these brackets they're
also called Dirac notation because they
I think were invented by Paul Dirac and
a physicist and so the one that we've
seen here is the kit this time it's not
containing a color but instead this
Greek symbol Sai and in the case of
quantum mechanics the kit contains
everything we know about the state of a
quantum object
so what kind of information can it
contain well a kit must contain the
information necessary to make physical
predictions about the behavior of the
state essentially just think of that as
like essentially what is the color of
the particle what is what is something
inherent about it
the example that we're going to go on to
use is that we're going to have this
bracket represent whether a particle is
spin up or spin down now spin is a term
used in quantum mechanics and I read a
little bit about it on brilliant on a
previous course before we get to this
mathematical course there's a bit of an
intro to the stern-gerlach experiment
where ya neutrons which are neutral
particles they're one of the three
subatomic particles in an atom so we've
got protons neutrons and electrons the
neutrons don't have a charge and so when
you fire them through like a series of
magnets you wouldn't expect them to be
deflected but we do find in this
experiment that neutrons are deflected
as if they're acting like they have a
charge or as if they're acting like tiny
magnets being attracted or repelled from
the magnets that they're passing through
so just to sort of explain why these
neutrons acted like tiny magnets we said
that they have a spin and the spin
doesn't mean that the neutrons are
actually spinning I believe was just
termed to be spin because objects that
do spin often act like magnets and we're
observing these particles act like
magnets so we say that they have a
inherent spin
when you fire the neutrons through this
experiment through these magnets what
you get on the other end is sort of two
bands of the neutrons some that were
death deflected upwards a certain amount
and some that we were deflected down a
certain amount the ones that went up we
turn they have a spin up property and
the ones that went down we say they are
spin down I guess that's all you need to
know about the spin at this point we
just want to understand the maths of how
you talk about this so just know that
we're going to have either an up arrow
or down arrow in our kit notation and it
just means what spin state is our
particle in so you're here's a bit of a
picture of this experiment I was talking
about we put in this that some particle
where we just say sigh we don't know
anything about the state of the particle
I guess and then it either becomes spin
up state or spin down state these two
states are mutually exclusive and
distinguishable so if you observe a
neutron the particle and the spin up
there is no chance that you will later
observe it in the spin down state so we
keep we keep that in mind because when
we want to find a mathematical
representation for our state's we want
it to share these properties that that
states can be physically distinct and
mutually exclusive this takes us back to
victors and working on a grid and of
three D axes and x y&z so orthogonal
vectors which is what these three are x
y&z are mutually exclusive because if
you're pointing in the X direction you
can't be pointing at all in the Z
direction that's sort of the way I
understand
so this is all to say that spin states
can also be expressed as vector states -
so it mentioned in the last chapter that
spin states always seem to be some mixed
combination of spin up and spin down
when we measure them so here's what I'm
saying that the state of a quantum
particle can be described as a linear
combination of some amount of spin up
and some amount of spin down they a and
B here are just numbers that represent
how much of the spin up and how much of
the spin down are combining to give us
our final state so that's like saying
how much of each color goes into
creating the final color if we were
still talking about a previous example
we only have a basis of two things here
like before we had three colors as our
building blocks here our building blocks
are just spin up and spin down we don't
need a third building block to be able
to describe our spin state so I'm saying
we only need a basis consisting of two
things here but we can check it sort of
mathematically so any basis set of
vectors must possess three important
mathematical properties normalization
orthogonality and completeness so we can
go on to see what these are about
now one term that I haven't used yet is
a dot product or an inner product
between two kits that's our state
reveals the amount of overlap between
the two kids so the state projected on
itself can be written as this where we
have the dot to represent the dot
product or you flip around the first one
to write it like this and it's just
saying how similar or what is the
overlap between
these two states in this case they're
the same so they will be complete
overlap and the answer will be one this
is kind of visually what we're saying we
have we had these two vectors and space
they're exactly the same
what is the overlap between them well
what is the inner product it is one if
kids have this property then they are
normalized and that's sort of what we
were talking about before is that they
add together to give one and you can
never have more than that so if we were
still in our color space example and we
did the inner product of two red states
we will get one because they're exactly
the same now we want to check that our
basis is orthogonal so if we have two
different basis states that there is no
overlap between them so in this example
if we do the inner products between the
Upstate and the downstate we find that
it is zero that means that they're
essentially at ninety degrees and
they're going in different directions
there's no redundancy I guess in our
basis states that we've chosen to use
out and now down again if we were to do
this on our color example and we tried
to see if red and blue were orthogonal
we would get zero we would find that
they are orthogonal there's no
similarity between them and they can be
used as two elements of our basis these
inner products can tell us if two states
are orthogonal but they can also tell
you or give you an idea of how similar
two states are so in this example here
we're considering these three colors are
pink a purple and an orange and we're
being asked which of these two colors
has an inner product closest to unity so
they're saying unity means one so we're
really being asked which two colors are
the most similar and the answer is the
pink and the purple just visually
looking at those they seem the most
similar to our eye and so you can even
prove it to yourself here that if you
did the inner product of these two
colors they would have give the answer
that is closest to one per our color
space example any of our colors could be
made using some combination of red green
and blue and for our quantum spin state
it is complete because any spin state
can be represented as a combination of
the kits up or down and this leaves us
with the properties of what is called an
orthonormal vector space and that's
essentially what we need it's a linear
algebra term it's what we need to create
a basis and it's going to be really
useful for describing the outcome of
like quantum mechanics experiments so
our basis here that we formed is our up
and down spin States we've seen that
they are normalized orthogonal and
complete so let's try and do an example
here using these properties of the spin
state find the inner product of the up
spin state on an unknown state vector
we're doing the inner product and
remember that's just checking how much
overlap there is between two things
we're doing the overlap between an up
state this sy function which it's
definition is actually up here it's some
unknown combination of up and down
I'll do this on paper so our general
state Victor the sigh is given as a
linear combination of our two orthogonal
basis kits that's the up and the down
state so we take this backwards kit here
and times it by everything in brackets
really we take what's here at the front
and times it by each term of the
brackets and we can take out the a and
the B because they are scalars they're
just numbers and can be moved about
freely we can simplify it based on what
we know about the inner products of
these spin States already that if
they're the same with complete overlap
it's 1 and that if they're the opposite
it's going to be 0 that means our final
answer just works out to be a question
here on the next page it's doing the
inner product of two sized states
remember we do have the definition of
that so try to work through that
yourself the answer is pretty easy to
check let's see if you can get it out if
you have managed to follow this fire
actually doing really well and you're
well on your way to be able to
understand a lot of experimental
interpretations of quantum mechanics
because this whole thing of taking two
wave functions which is what these size
represent and being able to do algebra
with them is really most of the mass
that you're going to need to be able to
do you're going to need to see like if
you compare wave functions between
particles you take inner products what
sort of results are you going to get
if you did get to this point I think
that's awesome if you were able to you
know work through this yourself and
actually understand the linear algebra
up to this point and how it can be
useful for constructing a basis how you
construct a basis and how we can do that
in quantum mechanics not just with
colors and not just with vectors but
actually with something as abstract as a
state then well done to you
I was really hazy on all of this until I
actually read through this material on
brilliant just like sort of before I
film this video so even though I'm here
sort of telling you what I know as if I
am the expert it's kind of what I've
just learned immediately before filming
so if there's a mistake four ways that I
can better explain things let me know
and I'm really excited to keep going and
to keep trying some more of these
problems but I really want to know what
you guys think and I want you to come
along with me and and help me define
what this learning is going to be and
what you actually want me to talk about
if you do want to work through this
course with me then you can go to
brilliant org slash Tibby's and sign up
for free there's also an annual premium
subscription and the first 200 people
that go to that link can get 20% off I
think that this particular course on
brilliant is really good because it
makes your learning active by giving you
fun and challenging problems to try
along the way so do check it out if
you're interested and thank you so much
for watching I'd love for you guys to
post questions down below and I really
want to improve the way I explain these
ideas so if you again like have
suggestions for me or things you'd want
me to explain please let me know